[Music]
kate middleton is showing off her
impressive piano skills
[Music]
during the royal carols together at
christmas concert special held at
westminster abbey the duchess of
cambridge debuted her surprising music
talent yup that's the royal on the piano
rocking a red dress for the special
occasion alongside scottish singer tom
walker the two performed his song for
those who can't be here
[Music]
this marks the duchess's first ever
public piano performance not only were
fans around the world impressed so was
walker who had this sweet reaction to
their duet on twitter just
one of those pinch yourself
crazy moments playing your song with the
member of the royal family is definitely
not your everyday occurrence so yeah i
just want to say a huge thank you
uh to the duchess of cambridge and to
the whole royal family for having me
be a small part of such an amazing
service turns out this moment was very
special for kate too ahead of the event
she reflected on the past year and
opened up about the importance of coming
together we've seen so many challenges
we've lost our loved ones we've seen our
frontline workers under immense pressure
and also we've been more emotionally and
socially distanced and isolated from
each other but i suppose through that
separation we've also realized how much
we need each other and how acts of
kindness and love can really bring us
comfort and relief in times of distress
and part of that comfort is celebrating
the holidays earlier this month kate and
her hubby prince william shared this
cute christmas card featuring their
family that's the two posing alongside
their children eight-year-old prince
george six-year-old princess charlotte
and three-year-old prince louis as for
how the royal celebrated the holidays
well just last week a source close to
the family told et quote prince william
and kate have been scheduled to stay at
anmer hall located on the sandringham
estate with their three kids adding they
have spent years past with kate's
parents in bucklebury berkshire which is
near windsor castle details are still
being worked out on how the move to
windsor castle will adjust christmas
plans and when it comes to william's
brother prince harry and his wife meghan
markle seems there's still tension
between the families following harry and
megan's decision to step back from their
royal duties and their tell-all
interview with oprah winfrey earlier
this year back in july royal expert
katie nicholl told et when she thinks
the brothers will be together again well
we don't know when we'll next see the
brothers together i think the idea of
christmases together is probably
not likely to happen this year of course
the covered pandemic does mean that
international travel is more challenging
i think we can be certain that harry and
megan will be coming back to britain i
think the platinum jubilee celebrations
in june 2022
are a likely opportunity for them to
come over to be a part of the official
celebrations of the queen's 70th year